Love Actually has somehow become one of
the most divisive Christmas movies of
all time if anyone brings it up at any
given time nineteen people like pop out
of the woodwork to give their hot love
actually takes which brings us right
into today's episode of are we okay with
this and I gotta be honest I might be a
Grinch here I am NOT okay with Love
Actually I don't understand it I didn't
see it for like a decade until after it
came out and then everyone's like you
haven't seen Moga actually and then I
finally watched it and I was like what
is this which is why I'm bringing in
someone who loves Love Actually et zone
Halle Stephen I'm here I'm here for it I
love Love Actually why do you love it
okay so here's why it's all about love
and who doesn't love love I mean this is
the universal thread that ties the human
race together no like let's be deep yeah
so it it markets itself that way it's
like this is the ultimate Christmas
rom-com love story thing and then you're
just like wait a minute I realized like
two and a half minutes into this movie
that it's kind of r-rated and they curse
a lot and then there's this whole
subplot where these like adult film
stand-ins fall in love while they're
naked the whole time and it's super
awkward so like who do you watch it with
your family your self confession next I
honestly watch this with my dad and I'm
not gonna lie like my whole family but
my dad was there we've all been there
we're watching the movie and I'm like oh
my god I forgot about this yes very
uncomfortable sad hear what you're
saying
there is gratuitous nudity however
there's also gratuitous love so you have
your sibling love you have your young
puppy love and you have like even your
run Unruh quited unrequited I don't know
how to say it either however you say it
they're British they say it's different
anyway but who doesn't love love I want
to go through some of these storylines
here I feel it's to it I don't know the
character's name so I'm gonna go with
the actors
sokurah Knightley is marrying she would
tell Ejiofor and then his best man best
friend Andrew Lincoln is secretly in
love with Keira Knightley past the nerve
to like ruin all our wedding footage by
just using weird creepy close close-up
shots of her face and then there's like
that I kind of cute card thing and I'm
like that's not cute
I get it like it's very romantic earth
like hyperbole at its max like it's
definitely Hollywood eyes but in between
these moments that you don't like you
have a Hugh Grant dance solo that is so
epic you have Billy Bob Thornton being
the US president you have a Mariah Carey
cover that is so freakin cute like I can
hardly stand it I mean it's just you
also have a great wedding surprise like
I know the video is creepy okay fair
enough but like I do like that moment no
I do like that moment I like everything
with Liam Neeson and his son but you
mentioned Hugh Grant and what I don't
love I love that storyline
except okay except the girl kiss
assistant that he's in love with is like
maybe a size six max and they keep
mentioning her like big size and coner
fat what the hell is that
yeah okay so I'm not okay with that I
definitely not okay I agree not a bad
and I'm not okay with Colin Firth
falling in love with that girl that he I
know there's a language barrier I
understand but they look with tell what
about the conversation they have a soul
tie though ash but don't you need to
know some fundamental things about your
your soul mate what are you into you one
heads maybe this is why I wanna race
wedding what's your favorite color
I mean yes get basic you're right you're
right it's romantic I mean come on when
she jumps in the lake after his papers
no I'm not okay with and I will admit
the one thing I don't love is the
infidelity storyline nothing about
cheating says Christmas like I just we
don't need that in our Christmas movie
no no I didn't like it so different
ative answer in the theme of are we okay
with this have I ruined your have I just
Grinch if I have I ruined your holidays
are you okay ruin your Christmas
you kind of trampled on my heart okay
yeah I'll recover I will still watch
this movie every Christmas until the day
I die I love this movie
I am 100% okay with it I am still how to
present that okay with it I'm sorry I've
ruined all your holidays let us know if
you're a die-hard Love Actually Stan
what you love about it what you don't
love about it I'm at ash Crossin I'm at
Holly underscore Stephen and sorry for
ruining her Christmas
you
[Music]